un mini marché dans un coin de la
cafétéria d'une école de la commission
scolaire english montreal une dizaine de
personnes autistes
ils font des exercices pratiques comme
de préparer des commandes en ligne
je rends photo je suis seul à chercher
le soleil vous prenez la photo vous
faites un crochet on repère on prend la
photo
l'idée du projet de formation et
d'intégration à l'emploi paul harris est
née avant la pandémie mais n'a pu
commencer qu'en juin c'est un grand
bilingue en partant on a dix
participantes qui était l'objectif
les âges ça va de 21 à 62 le déjà eu des
programmes pour les employés que toi
mais pas autant comme ça c'est qu'il est
différent c'est qu'on assure aux
participants comme pierre quenneville un
travail au sein du groupe provigo loeb
là ils sont à la recherche des employés
et puis nous on voyait vraiment est la
possibilité de faire des images de nos
besoins dans sept secteurs en termes de
l'industrie et aussi des besoins pour
les personnes autistes qui cherchait des
emplois
à mi parcours de la formation de neuf
mois
ils ont eu droit un premier contact avec
le centre de distribution où se
déroulera leur stage lors de
l'inventaire
c'est ça qu'on fait aujourd'hui que ceux
des bons produits dans les bons
emplacements provoquer des erreurs de
colette pour être d'envoyer les bons
produits au magasin les employés
formateurs sont agréablement surpris ça
se passe très bien les personnes se sont
plutôt très réceptive puis très ouverte
à qu'est ce qui se passe dans l'entrepôt
et le projet est soutenu par la haute
direction
j'ai appris à vivre avec avec cette
condition pour mon fils puis c'est
toujours difficile pour ces gens là de
pouvoir s'épanouir dans la vie qui est
plus difficile parfois c'est de
comprendre la tâche tout de suite c'est
juste de prendre un peu plus de temps
par contre toutes leurs forces les aides
au niveau des détails au niveau de
l'organe organisation au niveau de leur
écoute et ce n'est pas une oeuvre de
charité mais bien un programme d'équité
en emploi qui les prépare à contribuer
pleinement à la société
six coureurs pour un peu brisé des pg il
contribue vraiment à notre paysan c'est
pour ça moi je trouve ça important
plus on peut en parler plus d'autres
gens vont vouloir faire la même chose on
va faire l'activité du marché décolle à
pas de géant n'a pas eu de mal à
convaincre le géant de l'alimentation
les adultes autistes basé sur la
recherche aussi qui a été fait ailleurs
qui démontrent qu'ils sont aussi
efficaces sinon plus efficace il ya
moins de absentéisme qui de détails
vraiment important et sont soucieux du
détail trahit super fort que ça devienne
beaucoup plus que le projet pilote veut
travailler
une réponse à des besoins immenses dans
un domaine qui connaît un grand
roulement de personnel ici à nourrice
despatie radio canada montréal